Thank you very much.How are
you?
Well, it's Shinjuku and I'm the one who stands out, but how come I'm
here by chance?My
father is so close to me.He's
completely suspicious of me.In
fact, that's why the
club fans who are important to me are in a pinch
[Music]
Thank you for worrying about me.
Thank you, I'm fine. And it's strange.
No matter how many times I get tired and put my butt on the ground, it's like she's
pulling me
up, and I feel like I'm going to do my best again and again for Suwon.
[Music]
What's wrong with that?  I guess so.If that's the case, please say
hello to your father.Thank you very much.Sumi-chan, what are your
plans with your father?
Me too.
[Music]Please,
Earth, please.Thank you
very much.